c'est au parc du colosse que l'usap et
l'urss a choisi d'organiser une journée
de sensibilisation à la nutrition et aux
sports présents lors de cette action le
conseil départemental rappelle
l'importance d'informer les jeunes sur
la malnutrition en réunion nous avions
décidé de mener une action contre la
malnutrition l'obésité et serra d'aucune
action sportive
c'est très important parce que de plus
en plus maintenant depuis le 20e siècle
et on commence à approcher fast food il
ya peu d'obésité chez les jeunes surtout
les collégiens en particulier c'est pour
ça qu'il ya qu'il ya cette action
aujourd'hui et ce sera important d'en
parler parce que qui d'autre que des
jeunes puissent parler à d'autres jeunes
pour leur dire d'arrêter cette même
pression cette obésité la lui manger
bien manger de plus de fruits de légumes
tout ça et bien pas manger on peut pas
être aisé de ne pas manger des pam eric
adja tous les jours mais pas tout le
temps comment une fois le temps comme ça
mais avec des fruits légumes comme
manger bouger aux exigences accrues et
légumes par jour
le temps nous louons pour participe donc
c'est ce sont les jeunes qui après les
manifestations vont venir récupérer un
fruit local c'est qu'on l'a reçu des
agriculteurs locaux et du cou donc c'est
jeune pour partir en ayant déguster un
produit local donc c'est très important
pour nous bien se nourrir cela passe
aussi par des produits de qualité dans
les assiettes des collégiens
c'est un des axes de la politique des
élus du département
une volonté qui passent dans les
agriculteurs réunionnais puisque
l'objectif est de favoriser les plats à
base de produits pays dans les cantines
scolaires
nous sommes très attachés à travailler
avec l'ensemble nos agriculteurs sur
l'île pour justement permettre à
l'ensemble de nos collégiens parce qu'il
y va aussi aussi de la santé publique
donc de permettre un grand nombre de
de nos collégiens d'avoir de bons fruits
et légumes dans nos assiettes
on se doit de toute façon de travailler
avec nos agriculteurs parce que y va de
la santé publique de nos jeunes de nos
futurs citoyens de marque également
présents pour cette journée la direction
de la vie éducative met l'accent sur le
gaspillage alimentaires dans les
cantines
alors aujourd'hui on a bien fait en en
place avec la direction d'éducation
justement ce pour cette journée usep
unss courbe leur expliquer un petit peu
ce que c'est que le bien manger parce
que c'est le thème de la journée
d'aujourd'hui donc bien manger un bon
repas bon équilibre alimentaire et
surtout pour la nouveauté pour laquelle
le département s'engage c'est à dire le
gaspillage alimentaire puisqu'on a fait
un constat qui a énormément de
gaspillage dans la restauration scolaire
est aujourd'hui donc on veut
sensibiliser les jeunes sur ce fameux
gasquet une journée qui a permis aux
nombreux jeunes de découvrir diverses
activités sportives mais qui les a aussi
sensibilisé sur le bien manger